british prime minister boris johnson
announcing
major restrictions ahead of the holiday
as prime minister it's my duty to take
difficult decisions
to do what is right to protect the
people
of this country it is with a very heavy
heart i must tell you we cannot
continue with christmas as planned
now this has just happened in the last
hour prime minister johnson
ordering non-essential businesses to
close
in london and parts of southern england
due to the spread
of the coronavirus johnson also saying
that areas dealing with a high number of
covet cases
will not be able to take part in a
five-day easing of restrictions
on gatherings for the holidays big news
there